Speaker 1: Let's hear from some of our viewers
today. Now we are going to take some calls
via discord. You can find the discord at David
Pakman dot com slash discord now with I don't
even know how many people or subscribe 12000,
13000, something like that. Let's start today
with Josh from Toledo, Josh from Toledo. You
are on the air. What's going on?
Speaker 2: And not much is going on, just,
you know, finishing up semesters at college,
so I just want to pick your brain a little
bit if you're OK with it.
Speaker 1: You know, I am OK with it. However,
pick your brain. That's like one of the red
flags at a dinner party. If someone ever says,
I want to pick your brain, I try to head for
the hills because I'm about to get into a
horrible conversation. I'm going to assume
that because it's discord, it's not going
south.
Speaker 2: No, no, not at all. OK. I just
wanted to to get your opinion a little bit
on the problem of misinformation in the media
and how to combat it. Yes.
Speaker 1: That's the whole that's the whole
question, there was not a specific thing.
Speaker 2: Yeah, so I'm I'm trying to be general
here, I apologize. All of a sudden, you want
to live on and
Speaker 1: I've talked about the source of
a lot of this is we have people who reach
adulthood and they fall for this stuff. Earlier
this week, Tucker Carlson did a segment where
he simply said, I mean, this is just it's
so dumb, but a lot of people fell for it,
Tucker said. Why do we need any covid precautions
if the vaccines work? Maybe the fact that
we still have covered precautions is a sign
that the vaccines don't work and people are
not. Maybe it's that they're not confident
enough to think for themselves. Maybe it's
that they don't know how to pass and interpret
and analyze such a media message. But it's
like the answer is not enough. People are
vaccinated yet. It's really, really simple.
And the only way to really almost like, inoculate
people from that is you need to be teaching
critical thinking and media literacy much
earlier. We're not doing it. It's not getting
through. People are getting, you know, terrible
messages about how to think about things from
people they grow up around and schools that
are not working so well and people in their
family and Facebook and whatever else the
case may be. So it's not you know, there are
things we can do to try to fix media. But
the real solution would be to fix the viewing
public so they don't fall for this garbage.
Speaker 2: Well, I completely agree with you
on that, but do you think that there is that
there is some advantage in treating the current
media problem like trying to break a cult?
Speaker 1: Yes. No, no. Do you have to think
it is a cult like and we've talked to I have
interviews where we talk to cult experts and
they talk about how there is a cult like element
to what's going on. It should be treated that
way. It's an accurate analogy.
Speaker 2: OK, also, I apologize if I'm bringing
up topics that you have already covered a
lot.
Speaker 1: No problem.
Speaker 2: Yeah, the. I've been studying this
whole thing personally for about a year now
for what, my degrees?
Speaker 1: And listen, I love it, I'm going
to let you go just because I have so many
people waiting. I appreciate the one question.
Let's look at a second question. Maybe maybe
next time, just because there are a lot of
people waiting to get on. Let's go next to
Horace from Denver, Horace from Denver. You
are on the air.
Unidentified: Hi, David, how are you doing?
Speaker 3: What's up? You tell me I had a
question. Yeah, I saw the bonus show on Thursday,
which I caught later, so. Because that's why
I'm calling about it now. It was about that
new Utah law they've got. Or take off men
pay 50 percent of the pregnancy costs. Yes,
and I wasn't totally sure what your thoughts.
About that rule, the only thing I couldn't
glean from it, and then, you know what, your
child support laws in general.
Speaker 1: Yeah, so the story is one that
that that's being mentioned here that we talked
about on the bonus show earlier this week,
where Utah is moving forward with a law where
the biological father in a pregnancy is responsible
for 50 percent of the cost of the pregnancy
and birth, regardless of sort of like relationship
status or involvement with the biological
mother. And as I said on the bonus show, I
I like the idea that responsibility should
be shared, even though one of the two people
who are biologically the parents are responsible
for the actual birthing and carrying to term
of the child. The concerns include things
like, well, if you have a situation of either
domestic violence or a child conceived through
rape, and then you are in theory sort of like
tying a guy who may not be a good guy, who
the mother may not want involved to the child,
and what does that do? But can we just deal
with that by keeping the financial responsibility
separate from something that goes beyond that?
I mean, I think that's the complex.
Speaker 3: I got that. I got that. I was just
curious what you make of the. I guess there's
the argument out there, like, should men have
the obligation at all to be stuck financially
to a child at all? And that was the part I.
I've been curious about what
Speaker 1: what do you think should the.
Speaker 3: Um, I would. I kind of like what
they do in Sweden, which is they say you can
opt out of fatherhood. Now, they have a robust
social safety net that allows for, you know,
enables that much better. But there's still
the principal.
Speaker 1: There is still the principal. Yeah,
we do not have that system here in the United
States.
Speaker 3: Right. You know, that would enable
it, but then there's separate from that is
the principal. I happen to be of the persuasion
that it doesn't make a whole lot of sense
to obligate him financially to do that.
Speaker 1: And does the mother have that same
choice? Could a mother who's pregnant say,
I also don't want to have any financial responsibility?
Speaker 3: She has the ability to abort, but
she has all kinds of options there, comparatively,
you have a lot fewer options as a man and
it's kind of.
Speaker 1: You still have to be responsible,
though, in seeking out one case. Yeah, we
seem to be on a delay and but yeah, OK, I'm
going to let you go for now. The connection
is aggressively bad. I think there's a lot
of issues there wrapped up in that. Not not
all of which we are necessarily able to get
to right now. Let's go to Ricky from Charlotte,
Ricky from Charlotte. You were on the air.
Hey, David Pakman, I can hear you fine.
Speaker 4: So I wanted to ask real quick about
Florida. I think it's been a pretty big disaster
for the Democrats past few election cycles.
And the way that I started looks like this.
This is going to cruise to his reelection
just the way things stand right now. But I
did see that the agriculture commissioner
of Florida, she's like the only statewide
elected Democrat overall. She's a pretty generic
type Democrat, but she is pretty big on pro
legalizing marijuana. And they're also trying
to get a ballot initiative for legalizing
it in twenty, twenty two. Do you think if
she if they tried to run a campaign where
she is saying, you know, vote for me and vote
for legalizing weed, it polls pretty well
over 60 percent, which is what they need.
Yeah. And if you elect me, we're going to
implement it quickly without restrictions
to Stantis would ruin it and all that. Do
you think that could help them get him out
of office?
Speaker 1: I think it could. I mean, Florida
is such a strange place in terms of its election
dynamics and that it also has the the additional
kind of like X Factor of the Cuban population.
Of course, most voters from Central and South
America vote mostly for Democrats. Cubans
are the primary exception to that. You also
have a lot of folks who are you know, we could
say they colloquially live in Florida, but
they may not vote in Florida because they
only spend part of the year there. So sometimes
even like the people you see in Florida and
talk to aren't necessarily Florida voters,
you also have the opposite people who you
would think are voting elsewhere but are actually
voting in Florida. I think that there's a
real opportunity because we do see that sometimes
you see a dynamic in certain states where
even though they're still voting for a lot
of Republicans on issues and on ballot initiatives
and on local races, you start seeing them
move to the left and it can be like a leading
indicator as to what is eventually going to
happen. So I like the idea that you're suggesting,
I think trying to help the left by by attaching
a candidate potentially to a ballot initiative
or issue based campaign is a really great
idea. But I don't pretend to know enough about
the wackiness of Florida to be able to say
for sure whether it would be it would be successful.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I hear what you're saying,
and, you know, I just think that the Santurce
especially, he's he's a big political threat
to the Democrats. I feel like he's a really
good chance at being the nominee in twenty
four without Trump. So I think that if he
lost his reelection, that would be a big you
know, that would be a big blow to his nomination
chances.
Speaker 1: But, you know, I, I don't I think
you're probably thinking of this idea that
you're not going to do well if the last thing
you did was lose a race. But look at Joe Biden.
Joe Biden, you know, lost the primary in 2016
and then he won the primary and became president.
And you could say 20, 20 was an outlier. But
it's not that obvious to me that dissent is
somebody
Speaker 4: who he wasn't in the primary, but
he didn't run.
Speaker 1: Biden was not oh, wait, hold that,
no, Biden ran no, Biden did run in, did Biden
not run in 2016? Now, I don't even remember
Speaker 4: now because because because Beau
died and he because Beau died, like not long
before the election. He said he wasn't emotionally
ready. He was thinking, oh, yeah, that's right.
Speaker 1: What am I even talking about? Hey,
listen, you know what? You may be you may
be completely right on DeSantis. No, I think
the principle I think it's not totally clear
to me that a dissent is loss is the end for
him for twenty twenty four. I just think what's
the Republican anything could happen in the
Republican Party once Trump won a Republican
primary. It's sort of like all bets are off.
Anything could happen. And we already saw
Nikki Haley say this week that if Trump runs,
she won't and she will support Trump. I think
for the most part, people are going to be
deferring to Trump in twenty twenty four.
Speaker 4: Yeah, well, the the I'm just the
scientist just worries me because I feel like
you'd be a more effective is like if Trump's
fascism went to law
Speaker 1: school, right? No, I completely
agree with the whole thing. He has all the
same bad instincts and a morality of Trump,
but he's more competent and more polished
and more polished. Yeah, exactly. All right,
Ricky, thank you for the call. Appreciate
it. Yeah. All right. There it is.